nos jeunes malik oussékine mort la nuit
dernière et un beurre il est né il ya 22
ans à versailles est d'origine
algérienne il était étudiant à l'école
supérieure des professions immobilières
à paris et participer occasionnellement
aux activités sportives de l'université
paris dauphine
le frère de malik oussékine est le
propriétaire de la chambre qu'il
occupait témoigne à pascal deschamps je
suis bouleversée concernés et les
cheveux encore sous le choc je serai pas
vous dire grand chose encore j'ai mal
j'ai mal
est ce que vous savez si votre frère
participaient au mouvement étudiant
récents on écoute est un étudiant il
était concernée est concernée par par ce
qui se passait mais ce n'était pas du
tout un garçon violent
il a fait des ennemis de santé des
ennuis cardiaques
non non il avait d
des problèmes effectivement de santé
mais
c'est un sportif et il faisait des 10
sport a assez assez fatigant et n'avait
pas problème de 2k l'extérieur sans
suite le sait depuis
non seulement je vais louer une chambre
d'étudiant car il était étudiant et nous
parlions bonnes parfois de ses études et
ses orientations futures
il était parfait comme présentation
kenny politesse gentillesse de toujours
soigné
d'apparence ai je jamais je me
réceptionné le plus apporté d'être
militant de quoi que ce soit on
appartenait à quelques mouvements de ce
soir